Hi, I'm Peter Prevos, and I'll be talking about Emacs Riding Studio.
I'm a water engineer, associate scientist, and I dabble in theatrical magic.
And for each of those endeavors, I do a lot of writing.
I take notes, I write reports, articles, books, and websites.
I use Emacs for all my research, my writing, and my publishing.
Emacs Riding Studio is an opinionated starter kit for authors who write for humans,
not for programmers who write for computers.
And it consists of a configuration, some bespoke functions,
but are not yet a package, a website, and a book.
And a book is completely written with EWS itself.
The target audience are authors who are frustrated with using commercial software
and hoping from application to application to achieve an objective.
So these are people without any Emacs experience or coding skills.
And the objective is to teach these people how to use Emacs,
not how to configure Emacs to manage a complete writing project.
So Rye did a write a book about Emacs when the documentation is already so extensive.
Most Emacs documentation focuses on configuration,
burying potential new users with choices,
and it forces people to work on Emacs instead of with Emacs,
and it quickly can become a productivity sink.
Emacs is the ultimate free software platform, but with its freedom also comes a price.
And Barry Schwartz wrote about the paradox of choice, which is about the dramatic explosion
and choices in the modern world. Just think about the amount of effort I can take to decide
what serial to buy in a supermarket that you haven't been before, so many different choices.
And paradoxically, that's become a problem instead of a solution.
And Emacs can perhaps suffer from the same issue.
So another objective, using a COVID-19 TROP.
EWS is about flattening the curve. That is the learning curve by making these choices for the
new Emacs user and avoiding the paradox. So what about this EWS configuration?
I decided to stay as close as humanly bearable to vanilla Emacs,
and I said that tongue-on cheek, but also with some realism.
Centered around alt mode and the note for note-taking and sit-outs for accessing bibliographies,
and other convenience packages such as Vertical for Mini-Buffer completion,
there's a dictionary of Thizaurus and some other packages that are of interest to authors.
EWS uses the standard keyboard shortcuts.
Writing is much more about thinking than about maximizing the amount of words per minute.
And just think about that the most used function for authors is self-insert.
There's no need to use fancy keyboard shortcut systems when you write pros.
So how did that go about developing Emacs?
I declared Emacs bankruptcy, but we all have every now and then.
And I decided to write this book with vanilla Emacs, and only configure the system as well so
required. So the first thing I did, I hooked visual line mode to text mode and off I went.
And the configuration grew as the need arose.
And I was actually surprised with the how far you can get with just using vanilla Emacs.
And also developed two packages to enhance how I can use the note.
Let's get to a demo.
EWS is based on a typical research and writing workflow.
First step is you need to get some inspiration, and usually we do that by reading,
by watching, by listening. Then the next step is ideation.
You develop your ideas, summarized ideas, some other people write down your own ideas,
and for that you need a note-taking system. EWS also talks about managing bibliographies.
The third step is production. This is the actual writing process where, in this case,
the EWS book. And one side is finished. We convert this org mode file into something
that can be published. So that might be an e-book in an e-pop format or PDF for the interior of a
packet-back book, or perhaps as an e-book as well. And there's also configuration in Emacs
to produce MS Word documents if you need to collaborate with other people.
So let's jump in to Emacs and walk through this workflow, give you a very quick demonstration of
what's in the box. So the first step in the EWS workflow is inspiration. We all stand in the
shoulders of each other, some giants, most of the normal people. We get inspiration by reading,
listening, and watching. An Emacs can help you access text, sound, and video. It depends on
external software. An Emacs has a beautiful interface, and EWS helps you with the configuration.
But we also need a tool to manage our electronic library. And Bibtech, and CETA Package,
by Bruce Tarkins, provides a perfect interface to manage his literature.
So if I open my bibliography here, you see that I've got 1864 references in my Bibtech files.
And there's a whole bunch of stuff about, I guess, the weird things that I read.
Well, let's look for Emacs, right? Because that's a joined interest that we have.
And let's open here this paper by Markus Bildnerer, who did some research
using Emacs to teach data science and data science is my day job. So that had my interest.
So we have here a denote file, which I'll talk about in a second. There's a library file,
which is a PDF, but it could be a whole collection of different files and different formats,
even video or sound. We can create a new denote file, all as a link to the document object identifier.
So let's go to the PDF, and here we can now do our reading, so we can get our inspiration
by what Markus has written here about teaching data science with literary programming tools.
Next step is ideation. Taking notes is the core of all creativity. When I read that paper,
I might want to copy some ideas, or might get some of my own ideas, and I need to write that down.
I basically write everything in a paper notebook, but then I translate the things that are worth
keeping to the denote note-taking system. Now there are many systems that exist out there that promise
you note-taking happen when you just follow a certain process. My advice, don't worry about
settle-custom, barra or whatever is out there. Just write your notes and worry about
structuring all that later. Even Nicholas Lumen, the inventor of settle-custom, called his system,
the septic tank of ideas. I call my collection of notes, a primordial soup, from which my books emerge.
Now the note by Port Stavro is a flexible note-taking system that can implement
any of the popular methods, and I transfer thousands of files to this format, so all my information
is at my fingertips. So we can jump to the denote directory, and in my case that's the document notes,
and we see here the the marvel that is the note, which is its ingenious file naming convention
that has a timestamp, the title and some what do we call them tags or categories, which are whatever
you please. So this is a very quick way to find things, then there is an EWS diet.
Narrow function, and for example I can find anything underscore EWS means anything that has the EWS tag,
and there we go, it's narrowed down in in my EWS notes. Now this is all very well,
but I also decided to write a package called denote explore, which helps us sort of explore
these these collections of notes, and one of the fancy things we're going to do is do some
visualization. So let's go to the network function and we create a community of notes, so community
is a collection of notes that match a regular expression, underscore EWS, so all the notes here
that are on this list, the ones with the EWS tag, and in a second, so my browser pops up, and I shall
move that to my other window in a second, there we go. So denote explore creates a SVG file,
and creates an arrow between all the notes that are linked, it puts the title up there when the
note has more than two things going in or out, and we also can click on the note to read it in the browser
if you choose. If you set up Firefox properly, I'm sure it can also go into EMEX. So this is the note
tag that's available within EWS. Now, we've taken all these notes, now we need to start writing stuff,
and alt mode for me is the ideal tool, alt mode is what you see is what you mean, the text and
the syntax instruct a computer on how to produce the final result. And this means this means that one
file can become many different formats, an ebook, a print a book or a website, it doesn't matter.
Now, a lot of people talk about what you see, what you get, and that we should have what you see,
what you get more than EMEX, I think that's irrelevant, because showing the final result while you're
writing is actually a distraction. Traditional writing, producing the content, and designing the
layout and type setting are separate processes done by different professionals. In EMEX writing studio,
the writing is still done by a human, no provisions for large language models in EWS.
But layout and type setting is done by external software, BHCSS, LataqoXML, all mediated by alt mode.
And EWS also has some other tools for case conversion, it's always an dictionary that I haven't
got time to show, but what I will show you is how the book functions and then how we create this
publications. Okay, let's go to my project file. So these are the EWS chapters, and each chapter is
an org mode file. Let's go into the main document, which is set up with the Olivetti mode,
just to make it easier to read. And what we see here is all the fluff from org mode, so these are
all the various bits of method that are used to create the final result. And then for each chapter,
I have an inclusion. So this references another file. I've got some properties, in this case,
the forward is unnumbered, there's some notes, in this case, plot the actually wrote this for me,
so that we can jump into that text. And then what we see at the bottom here is some
inclusions for HTML, this is the E-pop version, but it's different in a lot of text. So again,
the same file can serve different purposes. So now let's, as the final part of this demonstration,
actually create the book, because the book's freely available, you can download the source files
from from GitHub, and you can roll your own. Okay, so let's open the dispatcher, we'll export the
large text, and we want to open the file. Now this takes a minute, because there's a lot happening
within all this in this code. So I'll shorten this video, I'll be signing it now.
And there we are. This is the E-max running studio PDF version, which will eventually become
the interior for the paperback version. So the EWS book is available in all major e-book shops,
and I'm also working on a paperback, which I hope to finish when E-max30 comes out,
but the org mode files that are used to produce the book, they're available in the GitHub
repository, so you can also roll your own, because the EWS configuration is the one that are used to
produce the book. Now some conclusions from this journey is that the best way to learn is to teach.
So that was my personal objective, and I learned a lot from systematically working out how to
implement the EWS workflow. One of the surprising things I learned is to have Google lines on
external software throughout the writing process. So I spent a lot of time in the book about explaining
these connections that E-max is not just a text processor, it is also an interface with other
software. Now future developments, as I mentioned, there will be a paperback version of the book when
E-max30 comes out, and I might reconfigure things a little bit. I'm only planning to update the
configuration when the package is break, or with another major E-max release, because I want to work
with E-max, not work on E-max. Now a big thank you to Port Stravery, who helped me with the
node packages, and also wrote the forward to the book. There's also several test readers that I met
through Mastodon that helped me out quite a bit, and of course all the E-max and package developers
without which none of this would exist. So thank you all for your attention, and I look forward to
your questions and suggestions.